i worked out the other day before 10 a.m
i'd seen three penises that i hadn't
asked to see
if i'd walked out into the street to get
a coffee and three men had flashed me
on the way i'd be i'd be in pieces i'd
be traumatized but there is honestly
something about when it's online
and i hate to admit this i've become so
used to it
i knew i wanted to be an actress i
didn't quite know how i was going to go
about it but i just knew that's what i
wanted to do
i found out there was an audition for
something called baggy trousers
which is now it was late to the
in-betweeners
and i said to my agent i really i really
want to go for this it's a new
uh six-part series on e4 it would just
be the best thing ever and
he was kind of going it's so unlikely
it's so unlikely don't get your hopes up
but he sent me to the audition
and on my third audition i by this point
i wanted it so badly and i knew
that this job was going to change my
life i didn't know how big it was going
to be but i just knew that it was gonna
be big
and i i turn around in the audition and
i would never do this now because i know
the etiquette
i turn around and i on my way out i said
i'm just gonna say nobody else in that
room can do this part better than me
charlotte hinchcliffe is made for me
and then i walked out and i got the part
the next like that day
i was 17 when i did the first series of
the in-betweeners
and i started doing lads mags were you
posing in your pants
um and at the time i've got to be honest
at the time and people asked me this a
lot whether
you know it was like a really sort of
scary strange thing being
a sex symbol at such a young age but i
was loving it i was just
i i it was it was my job i i felt like
it was my job to pose in my underwear to
promote a tv show
or a movie or something i didn't sit
there
and think oh my god this is so exposing
this is too much
i think this now now that i'm a grown-up
it's one of those things i reflect on
and go wow you know i look at 17 year
olds now they look like babies
um and i look at pictures of me back
then with my skinny little body my big
lollipop head
and i look at that and i think oh my god
i was so young
and actually what i think is is unusual
is that i was so comfortable and fine
with all those things did you feel any
pressure then to look a certain way
i feel a pressure to look a certain way
every single day
i think about my weight 95
of the day when i was sort of 16 15 16
i hadn't i'd never really worried about
my weight because i was
in my head i was a slim teenager and
i never had any problem getting a
boyfriend and you know that was all fine
it was when i started doing the
in-betweeners that people online started
calling me fat
and that really surprised me because i'd
never thought about my weight in a
negative way before
and because you know most actresses a
lot of actresses are much smaller than
size six or eight and i was a sort of
size 10
12 girl and i've just never been able to
get down to the size
that people i don't know people are
expecting me to be i don't know what
people want
from me and even when even when it's
safe you've lost like three pounds and
you're feeling yourself
and you're like yeah i've lost a bit of
weight and then somebody shuts you down
and goes
you're still a fat pig it absolutely
destroys me it's
awful it's absolutely horrific you also
receive some
unwanted sexual comments online what
i've really noticed is that i'm so used
to having men
hurling abuse at me in the street and or
in a bar
um i'm so used to that i've had it my
whole life
what i've been interested to see in the
last
kind of last decade i guess where social
media is the biggest it's ever been
the online abuse and the sexual
harassment
is just out of control it's completely
out of control
for some reason there's this blind spot
where if it's online
you don't receive any consequence
at all how many sexual messages from
stranger do you receive now
i receive on a daily basis
oh i mean
it's hundreds hundreds
i received hundreds of messages can you
tell us some examples
yeah sure no problem
i've never i've never said these
outlines it's quite daunting sort of
saying them on a camera
um let daddy make you come like the
filthy [ __ ] you are
let me impregnate you you filthy [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i know that you're a filthy cumslet i
know what you like
oh this is this is an interesting one
i'm a dad of four kids why don't you be
naughty with me like you always are with
everyone else and let this bad daddy
spunk all over your face
no thank you daddy i worked out the
other day before 10 a.m
i'd seen three penises that i hadn't
asked to see
three you know [ __ ] shots that have been
sent through
if i walked out into the street to get a
coffee and three men had flashed me
on the way i'd be i'd be in pieces i'd
be traumatized but there is honestly
something about when it's online
and i hate to admit this i've become so
used to it
i just kind of go oh god
oh you know when i get these messages i
do always look on their profile to kind
of see what i'm intrigued to see what
sort of person
they would be what life they have
sometimes it's you know completely
anonymous
um no photo and they've obviously just
created an account to just
sail these awful things to god knows how
many poor women
it goes from teenage boys to middle-aged
men
to really old men old single men that
are probably desperately lonely
and older men who are married with
children and they have daughters
in their profile pictures you know and
this this particular guy that um
i'm a dad of four kids i thought that
can't be true and i went on his profile
he's got a full
family full life and i just can't
believe the
like how how brazen he is to kind of to
do that
not you know not assuming that i would
come out and completely out him
i could easily do that how does it make
you feel
like my heart's beating really fast at
the moment my heart's like and i'm
sweating
um i think the words that i'm saying
like i'm shaking as well
really strange um i think as well
because
i've always been known as like a
charlotte big jugs
girl you know i'm charlotte big jugs i'm
the fun party girl i'm blonde i've got
boobs
i'm a i'm an outrageous flirt what
frightens me
is that i'm that is the persona that
i've always put out there to people so
it's
it's it's people saying to me um
i know that's what you're like so that's
why i i'm gonna say this to you because
i think you're gonna
like what i'm gonna say i don't know it
makes me embarrassed because
it makes me go well this entire time
i've posed
in my underwear in lads mags and i've
written sketch shows
about my one night stands and laughed
about it
and i've i've
i've i've got a cleavage my cleavage is
out today
you can't help there is a little thing
in your mind going
yeah but and and i and i hate myself
saying it but you go
what do you expect um what'd you expect
and i got oh my god
why am i thinking that that's a terrible
thing to think makes me question
everything that i
am and everything i put out there and
that's what makes me feel
strange reading this out
the horrible thing about it is that
nobody is around
to kind of go oh you say to the person
don't [ __ ] do that that's horrific
it's just they're allowed to just to do
it and i'm just i'm subjected to it
on my own in my home uh i don't have a
partner you know i'm by myself
and it does make me feel scared to kind
of live on my own i
um i've had people now messaging me
knowing that i live on my own
saying that they're outside with a
telescope and they know what my cushions
look like on my sofa and
recently a guy actually followed me home
it was just it was when we were allowed
to go to the
pub again um i was walking home from the
pub
and it was it wasn't even that late it
was probably about nine o'clock or
something so it's dark
and he just you know he's riding up next
to me on his bike and he's
he's like i recognize you and i'm like
oh yeah just kind of
walking on um he was like i know and he
was just sort of saying all these things
in my ear like saying
i know what you like um i know what sort
of girl you are
um you [ __ ] you love being single and
um
let me show you what what i can do to
you let me show you what a good time i
can give you and
like so that was physically in the flesh
and i ran indoors and i was so upset and
so frightened
um so it's just it's that i have that
man
on the bike in my ear but just
constantly online
um and it does it starts to chip away
yeah
it does now is would you want to say
oh my god i wouldn't i if you if you
sort of
say if somebody said to me you've got
the opportunity to face him now would
you no i
probably wouldn't oh my god it makes me
feel sick just thinking about this
horrible faces they're disgusting
and i feel so sorry for their families
not knowing that that's what they're
doing
do you know what i'm a brave girl i
probably would face it
but oh my god it would be probably one
of the hardest things i'd ever
have to do does that make you think so
much less of
men in general no no it doesn't
um because i am very lucky that i
i've got a lot of wonderful men in my
life i think that's why i don't
completely crumble over things like this
because
i have incredible men in my life i've
been extremely extremely loved by my
father and my uncles
my cousins and i think in that sense i'm
lucky you can't generalize
you know it's so easy to go like ah men
are disgusting as you know they just
think with their dicks and all that but
i don't believe that i think that
a certain type it takes a certain type
of person
must have such an impact on your mental
health
it has just been recently that i've
opened up about it because
there was a point where i was sat there
and i was so shocked
by how i was feeling i was questioning
everything about myself i was
questioning my entire persona
i was i was i ended up sitting there
thinking is this why i'm single
because this is what this is how men
look at me and they just see me as a
piece of trash that they can just you
know flip over and kind of
treat how they want this is what the
messages were kind of doing to me
i remember when i wrote my sketch show
which i'm so proud of
um it's the best thing i've ever done in
my life and i'm a you know a sexually
liberated woman i stand up there and i
talk about all these things the reason
why i'm doing that is because i'm trying
to take ownership again of my sexuality
because men my entire life have uh
have commented on my body my boobs um
the men that i've dated
and this is my way of taking back all
that control
uh and standing there and kind of saying
you know what
[ __ ] you because i this is my body
these are my thoughts these are my
experiences my and all the things i'm
talking about this is my
my sexual experiences my sex my
everything this is you can't and they
they can't take that from me then i feel
if i stand up there
as a sexually liberated woman and say
all these things i feel like i'm taking
back
some control i i feel personally
because when i'm up there and i'm
talking about it or oh my god it feels
great
it really does feel like i'm kicking
every single guy in the bollocks that
has
ever ever said anything along those
lines to me
[Music]
at that point in my life like there's
there's no look there's not an easy way
for my man to have
abounded into my room and told me but
she just opened my door on a wednesday
morning
and said stephen your dad's dead he's
hung himself the first thing i did was
i remember punching the wall so angry
got up
walked to one of my friends built a
spliff tried to make sense of it and i
went through a whole spectrum
of emotions